in this video we're going to play a bit
of a game I have three different data
sets here and we need to figure out
which of these data sets come from
either a linear linear quadratic
quadratic or exponential function
exponential function and just as a
reminder linear function is of the form
Y is equal to MX plus B a quadratic is
of the form Y is equal to a x squared
plus BX plus C and an exponential is of
the form Y is equal to some constant
let's call it a times some number to the
X power now the way to tell them apart
and I'm going to actually show you it'll
be it'll probably be intuitive for you
for a linear function and maybe even for
an exponential the quadratic the
technique I'm going to use might not be
intuitive and I'll actually prove it for
it to you in the next video or at least
show you example in the general case of
why it makes sense but the way to tell a
linear function is that when you
increment X by a constant amount Y will
always change by a constant amount so
when you always increase X by 1 y should
always increase by a certain amount so
let's look let's just using that as our
kind of our first guideline let's see
which of these represent a linear
function so over here so in all of these
examples as we go from one data point to
the next we're increasing X by one and
it's very important that you pay
attention to that because if you'd if
you weren't you would have to adjust
things a little bit but in all of these
we're always increasing X by one so
let's look at our change in Y's when we
go from the first data point to the
second data point our change in Y is 60
when we go to the second to the third
our change in Y is 90 so that
immediately tells us we're not dealing
with a linear function when our change
in X is 1 our change in Y here is 60
then it's 90 and then as you go here
what it's like 135 so this one is
clearly not linear let's look at this
one over here our first change in Y is 2
then our next change in Y is
once again not linear as we increment X
by by a constant amount our Y does not
increase or decrease at a constant
amount so once again this one is not
linear now let's look over here once
again we're increasing X by 1 through on
every data point and when we go from
this first data point to the second data
point y decreases by 3 then we go from
the second to the third once again y
decreases by 3/3 to the fourth y
decreases by 3 1 to negative 2 once
again decreases by 3 and we just keep
decreasing by 3 so whenever we change X
by 1 when we increase X by 1 Y goes down
by negative 3 so we actually have a
constant slope we could say our change
in Y over change in X is equal to when X
is goes up by 1 Y goes down by 3 this is
the definition of slope this is the M in
this equation right here our changes are
constant so this one right here is
linear this one right here is linear not
quadratic there's an interesting we
could call it a trick right now because
I haven't really showed you why it works
but a quadratic your changes in Y the
the changes in Y are not going to be
constant as was the case in the linear
but the change in the changes of Y will
be constant let me write that down it
probably makes no sense to you right now
but when you see an example a little
it'll be kind of fun change change in
change in Y constant constant let me
show you what I mean so over here let's
look at this first one over here so we
went from 120 to 180 that was an
increase of 60 180 to 270 that was an
increase of 90 then we went from 270 to
405 which is an increase of 135 now when
I talk about the change in the change of
Y these are the change in Y's what are
the change in the change of Y's well we
went we had a change of 60 then we had a
change of 90 so that was a change in the
change of Y of 30 or
difference of the difference you could
view it that way if you like then we go
from then we had a change of 90 and then
we had a change of 135 so the change in
the change let's see that is 45 so here
the change in the change in Y or the
difference of the difference is not
constant we grew by 60 and then we grew
by 90 which was 30 more than 60 then we
grew by 135 which is 45 more than 90 so
this is not constant over here so this
tells us that this is not a quadratic
function now let's look at this over
here the change in the chicken Y let's
write that down
this clearly was not linear we increased
by 2 here increased by 0 here increased
by negative 2 here increased by negative
4 here increased by negative 6 there the
change in Y's are definitely not
constant but let's look at the change in
the change of Y's so we increased by 2
then we increased by 0 so this was a
negative 2 in the change in the change
of Y or the difference of the difference
then when you go from 0 to negative 2 we
changed by 0 then we changed by negative
2 that is a change in the change of
negative 2 then you go from negative 2
to negative 4 a change in the change of
negative 2 this one's starting to look
quadratic we changed by negative 4 then
we changed by negative 6 once again a
change in the change of negative 2 so
this data right here fits fits our
requirement for quadratic and I'm just
kind of giving it to you as a trick
right now in the next video actually
show you why this works I'll show you an
example or just so you get the gut
feeling of why it should work so this
one right here is quadratic so you might
say hey Sal you know give us three
examples one of them's going to be
linear one of them is going to be
quadratic one's going to be exponential
this one's probably going to be
exponential and you are probably right
but let me give you the way that we can
figure out if something is exponential
so when x increases by one in an
exponential you should always have a
constant multiplying factor so when you
go from one term to the next term they
should be that they should be a similar
ratio from one to the next
set of just subtracting in this case 120
from 180 and 180 from 270 to test for an
exponential function what you want to do
is check whether the ratio of when you
increment X by constant amount whether
the ratio of the Y's are the same so
when we increase X by one y went from
120 to 180 so it increased by 18 over 12
is 1.5 so when we went from this term to
this term let me clear all of this stuff
out here let me clear this so when we
went from here to here this was times
one point five and then when we go from
180 to 270 once again that looks like
we're going times one point five right
half of 180 is 90 add that to 270 so
once again we're increasing by one point
five to 72 405 half of 270 is 135 that's
how much we're increasing by so once
again we're increasing by one point five
so every step of this way we are
multiplying that the previous term by
one point five to get the next and that
actually tells us that actually tells us
that this right here is a one point five
but the our point here isn't to actually
figure out the formula so the point here
is to classify them so now we know
definitively that this right here at
least given the data we have is an
exponential exponential function anyway
hopefully you found that hopefully you
found that fun